all right good morning everybody the
knights in some trouble here down two
nothing to the avalanche game three is
tonight
in t-mobile arena now this morning for
striking gold we're gonna strike some
silver and black as well okay the
raiders are holding workouts
this month in henderson the otas stands
for organized
team activities and the sports landscape
has gotten pretty fun here the last
few years pretty crowded that's nice
there seems to be some crossover though
between the knights
and the raiders so we wondered are the
raiders checking out the knights and
their playoff run this season
i've never been to a golden knights game
i'm excited to watch them play seriously
i've never
you know been to a hockey game in
general so i'm just excited i hear the
atmosphere is unbelievable
you know vegas just gets up for it and
that energy and so hopefully uh maybe
friday i'll be able to go
and watch them yeah i'm checking them
out they
they definitely got their work cut out
for him with colorado but it's gonna i
feel like it's gonna be a great series
probably one that's gonna go seven games
uh and i
definitely plan on tuning in tonight and
you know maybe catching
another home game once they come back to
vegas so here we go game three tonight
at t-mobile arena there will be a packed
house
in the arena for the game 100 fan
attendants there
and perhaps a few raiders players in the
crowd i could imagine have a good friday
everybody i'm ron futrell
eight sports now